ALLISON: OK, hello and
welcome, everybody,
to today's Authors
at Google Talk.
I'm incredibly excited
to be welcoming
Liz Wiseman, bestselling author
of the book "Multipliers."
And now here with us
today to talk about
her new and latest
content, "Rookie Smarts,
Why Learning Beats Knowing
in the New Game of Work."
We've been incredibly
lucky to work with Liz
over the last few
months, as she's
been looking at this content.
And I'm incredibly
excited for the content
that she'll be sharing with you
over the next 30, 35 minutes.
So welcome, Liz.
LIZ WISEMAN: Thank you, Allison.
Thank you for being
here and tuning in.
This book, really, is Part
Two of my post-Oracle therapy.
So I want to start at the
very beginning of my career.
I began Oracle right
out of business school,
and all of my training
was in business.
Now, I had taken a Fortran
class and I had worked as a TA
in the computer lab, and so
that somehow seemed like enough
for Oracle to give me my
very first job teaching
programming to all of the
new computer science grads
that we were hiring from
the best universities out
of the best programs.
And so I got to teach
programming to programmers,
knowing next to nothing
about programming.
And it was a really
interesting, wild ride.
And then my second
job at Oracle was
to run the training department.
So I'm a year out
of school, and they
say, Liz, the company's
growing like crazy.
We need to train our workforce,
which is growing rapidly.
You are now the training
manager for the company,
and Larry Ellison wants
a corporate university,
so go build Oracle University.
And I knew even less
about doing that than I
did about teaching programming.
And really, with actually no
ideas of my own to draw upon,
I started to kind of
reach out and talk
to all the other
executives and figure out
what really needed to be done
to transfer knowledge and grow
this rapidly-growing
software company.
Although my self-confidence
was probably high,
my situational confidence
could not have been lower.
So I stayed really
close to my stakeholders
and worked in thin
little pieces,
getting feedback along the way.
We kept things really
simple, because at this point
I didn't know enough to
even complexify things.
That was my second job.
And so, my career at Oracle
went on and on with very similar
kind of roles, being
asked to do things
I knew almost nothing about.
Just at the point
where I'm starting
to feel like I know how to do
my job, 16 years into my career
it occurs to me that, finally,
for the very first time
in my career, I have a
job I'm qualified for.
And it felt awful.
It felt disappointing.
It felt sure, it felt easy.
So it was then that I left
the cradle of my career
and went out to do
something that I didn't yet
know how to do.
And as I left Oracle, I felt
unsure and I felt vulnerable.
And it wasn't because I was
stepping out into the unknown.
I felt unsure because
I felt as if I
was carrying a
liability with me.
And I started to
wonder, how might
what I know get in the
way of what I don't know?
And about this time, a friend
of mine asked this question.
He said, Liz what's the
question that you're
going to hold for
this next year?
And I wrote this question down.
How does what we
know get in the way
of what we don't know,
but perhaps need to learn?
Because I could see that
the world is changing.
And that's really
the question that I
want us to explore
together today.
Is there power in not
knowing how to do something?
Can being inexperienced
actually be an advantage,
and can it be an advantage right
now, when the world of work
is changing really fast?
And this is an interesting
place to be talking about this.
We all feel it.
We feel that the amount of
information is increasing.
More and more people are
getting access to it,
and technology's allowing
our business cycles
to spin faster and faster.
And our innovation cycles are
spinning faster and faster,
too, which means,
what we know doesn't
stay true for very long.
That knowledge is also
becoming obsolete faster.
As I was doing my
research, I pulled
a few data points together
and did some calculations
and realized that if you
work in STEM-- in technology,
in science, like virtually
everyone here on this campus
does-- what we know
today, about 15% of that
is likely to be
relevant in five years.
In this environment, perhaps
the speed at which we learn
is more valuable
than what we know.
So it was with this
broad curiosity
that I set out to
do my research.
And Elise Foster, who's a
member of my research team,
is here today.
And what we did
is, we studied how
experienced people versus
inexperienced people
approach their work.
And I want to share
that with you.
Before I share the results of
what we found in the research,
I want you to spend a
little bit of time thinking
about when you were a rookie.
And what I mean
by rookie is, when
you are new to something
important and hard.
Doing something important and
hard for the very first time.
And I'm going to ask you to
go back, to go back in time,
go back in place to when you
were in a rookie assignment.
And I'm going to
ask you to lock that
in and start to
think about that.
And let me share with
you one such rookie move,
one of many stories
of inexperience
and the value of that that
came out of my research.
This is Stephanie DiMarco.
She graduated in 1979
from the University
of California Berkeley.
Graduates from Cal.
She takes a job in the financial
services industry where
she works for a
small trading firm,
and her job is to keep track
of the trading for this firm.
And very quickly she
finds out that this
is a really difficult
job to do manually.
This is just the beginning of
the era of enterprise computing
and automation.
She can see what's
happening around her.
She goes to her
management and advocates
that they automate this process.
Now, at the time, the
computing industry
was dominated by what
we call "big iron."
Deck minicomputers the
size of a delivery truck,
housed in a data center,
controlled by air conditioners,
with a price tag of $30,000.
It was the standard computing
platform at the time.
Well, $30,000 is a pretty hefty
price tag for this small firm.
Now meanwhile, the computer
wars are starting to wage.
And actually, Stephanie with
this work that she begins,
finds herself right in
the middle of these wars,
because in the early
'80s, IBM comes out
with the first
personal computer.
Can't do much.
Everyone considers it a toy.
Don't even think it
has a hard drive.
It's got a price tag of $1,500.
Well, within a couple
release cycles,
IBM is offering a PC
that costs $5,000 that
has the same computing power
as this Deck minicomputer
with the price tag of $30,000.
And Stephanie says,
well, why can't we
build these information systems
and these automation systems
on a PC?
And what do the
industry pundits say?
It's a ridiculous idea.
That's a toy.
You can't build robust,
scalable, secure information
systems to track financial
trading on a toy.
Well, what Stephanie sees
is not only something that
seems possible, it
seems inevitable to her.
She, with a partner, starts
a firm, Advent Software,
with the goal of building these
high-performance information
systems on a low-cost
computing platform.
This is a picture
of Stephanie at one
of the early trade shows.
She recalls someone referring to
Advent Software as that company
from California that's
using baby computers
and run by a little girl.
Well, Stephanie and her
team built the product,
and within a year they've
now got a working product.
And soon they have a customer.
And two customers,
and three customers,
and they're building
customers one at a time.
And soon, Stephanie
is schlepping
through the streets
of Manhattan,
calling on financial services
firms and selling this product.
This is Stephanie today.
She took the company
public, and the company now
has a market capitalization
of $1.5 billion,
managing trillions of
dollars worth of assets.
This value and this
wealth creation,
because one person, who was
new, under-qualified, but could
see something that
everybody else missed.
She stepped down as
the CEO of Advent
to make room for the next
generation of leaders.
A rookie move.
Perhaps not a sign
of a mistake, a goof,
a clumsy kind of bumbling
move, but perhaps a rookie move
is brilliant about to happen.
Have you been thinking about
one of your rookie moves?
Because I'm going to
ask you to kind of
join me in this conversation.
And what I want you
to do is, I want
you to start by
teleporting yourself.
And I mean "Star
Trek Enterprise."
Get into that teleporter
and take yourself
back to when you were new to
something important and hard.
And if you're here on
campus, you've got a handout.
You can flip it over.
There's a few
questions on the back.
If you are watching
this, I'm going
to pop up a few questions.
Here's what I want you to do.
I want you to take two
minutes and identify
one of these rookie challenges,
and answer these questions.
And let me pop these up here.
What could you see that
other people couldn't see?
Who did you seek
out for guidance?
What did you do to
prove yourself quickly?
How did you get feedback and
how did you stay on track?
And how to recover
from mistakes?
So let me give you just a couple
minutes to reflect on that.
See if you can answer as
many of these as possible,
and then I want
to hear from you.
OK, let me ask you share
some of the observations
from your own rookie experience.
Some of you may have gone
back many, many years-- maybe
even decades-- to when you were
brand new to the workforce.
Some of you may have gone
back just a couple weeks,
when you're a mature,
experienced professional,
but you are tackling
something that you've never
attempted before.
Tell me about your experience.
What did you do?
Well, could you
first start me with,
what could you see that
other people couldn't?
And just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: Technology [INAUDIBLE]
LIZ WISEMAN: So you saw new
technology on the horizon
that other people
didn't know existed.
AUDIENCE: Right.
LIZ WISEMAN: What else could you
see that other people couldn't?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LIZ WISEMAN: So you could see
new tools, new methodologies.
Who did you seek out?
How did you stay on track?
Just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LIZ WISEMAN: Yeah.
The need to move quickly,
and to create a prototype
and prove the relevance.
It's one of the things
that we've found,
is that when people are
brand new to their work,
they tend to work
in thin slices.
What else did you do to get
feedback, to prove yourself?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LIZ WISEMAN: Yeah, shared
results more quickly,
because we're trying to get
feedback to stay on track.
Any other thoughts about
reflecting on your own work
experience and what you did?
Let me share with you what
we found in our research.
So we studied about 400
scenarios, pieces of work,
ranging from develop a
training class to troubleshoot
an escalated issue, to
build a corporate campus.
Actually, a campus
like here at Google.
And we looked at
how people operated,
how they thought about
their work, what they did,
and how they performed,
asking managers to rate
an experienced person
versus an inexperienced.
Here's what we found in studying
those different scenarios.
The first thing we found is
that experience obviously
has some upsides.
As we gain experience,
we gain knowledge.
We amass more data
points that gives us
greater power of intuition.
We build confidence.
We build credibility.
We often amass resources
that prove very helpful.
But there's also a number
of troubling downsides
and blind spots.
What happens once
you know the pattern?
What happens?
AUDIENCE: You follow it.
LIZ WISEMAN: You
follow a pattern.
You say, I've seen this before.
And you follow it.
It's actually one of the
signs of intelligence,
is how quickly we can spot
patterns and follow them.
Is there someone here
in the room, preferable
with a big, loud voice,
who can read this for us?
OK, right here.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
matter in what order
the letters in a word appear.
The only important thing is
that the first and last letter
are in the right place.
The rest can be a total
mess and you can still
read it without problem.
LIZ WISEMAN: OK, and
keep going for us.
AUDIENCE: Similarly, your mind
is reading this automatically,
without even thinking about it.
LIZ WISEMAN: What happens
once we know the pattern?
What does our mind do?
AUDIENCE: Fill in blanks.
LIZ WISEMAN: We start
to fill in the blanks.
And sometimes we
fill in the blanks
with what we want to see,
rather than what's there.
Often, once we know we know
that there's a pattern,
we overlook mistakes.
Hence why none of us really
can copy edit our own writing.
Often, once we know the
answer or the pattern,
we stop seeing new data points.
We stop seeing
new possibilities,
new tools, new methodologies.
Often we stop seeking out input.
We often stop seeking feedback.
And with experience inevitably
comes bad experience.
What happens once we
develop scar tissue?
Now, we all know what
physical scar tissue is,
and we've all got our scars.
I have a couple scars on
my knee that remind me,
don't race your husband
down Wildcat at Alta.
Landed me in emergency surgery.
ACL reconstruction.
And I think about
that every time I'm
at the top of a mogul run.
But what does professional
scar tissue look like?
When someone suggests
something and you've
had a bad experience with this.
Quickly the hands
go up, we stop that.
I've done that before.
It did not work out.
Well, it's as if they touch
this very sensitive scar tissue,
and it creates a
set of blinders.
The other thing we've found
is that ignorance actually
can drive top performance.
And by ignorance I
don't mean stupidity.
By ignorance, I mean
intelligent lack of knowledge.
And rather than
share lots of data
points that we've found from
the research, what I want to do
is just kind of
walk with me up what
it's like when we're climbing
a steep learning curve,
and contrast it to
how we tend to operate
when we have experience.
Now, at the beginning
of this learning curve
is kind of the
phase of ignorance.
And this is where, truly,
ignorance is bliss.
And we're asked to
do something hard,
or maybe forced to do
something new and hard,
and we're telling ourselves,
how hard can that be?
I've got this.
Because we don't
know how hard it is,
often we just venture out.
We see this kind of gentle
learning curve, and we embark.
But once we get
out there, we start
to get our very first answer to
that question, and we find out,
it's actually
really, really hard.
And we start to look
around, and what do we see?
We see the curve
getting steeper.
We start to see the gap.
The gap between what we
know and what we can do,
and what our peers
are able to do,
or what's needed for the job.
And this is where,
typically, we start to panic.
We start to panic,
and it's a panic
that either causes us to hold
back and get frozen in place,
or to propel ourselves
up this learning curve.
We kind of start out in what
I call "backpacker mode,"
unencumbered.
But once we're out there
in this state of awareness,
we start to look
for who can help us,
and we move into what I think
is the most powerful form
of learning, is
desperation learning.
We don't learn because
there's a talk on campus.
We don't learn because there's
a course or a curriculum
or a competence model.
When do we learn?
We learn when we have to.
We learn when it's too
painful not to learn.
And this is where we kick into
what I call "hunter-gatherer
mode."
We're looking around, because we
now understand how hard it is.
And we're looking
around for who can help.
There's got to be someone
who knows what we do.
And we tend to go into
this seeking mode.
We found in the research
that, on average,
inexperienced people
seek out expertise
at five times the level
of experienced people.
In other words, if you ask an
experienced person to do a job,
you tend to get one
person's expertise.
But when you ask
a rookie, someone
who doesn't know
what they're doing,
you tend to get five
people's expertise brought
to bear on the problem.
A more diverse view of
expertise, and often
a more current view.
We then go into what I call
"firewalker mode," because we
are anxious at this stage.
We still have a huge gap
that we've got to close.
And so anxious, we
operate cautiously,
kind of taking
very careful steps.
But we're also anxious
to prove ourselves,
and so-- as Allison
said-- we operate quickly,
kind of like the way someone
would walk the hot coals.
Very cautious about
what you've got to do,
but moving very, very
quickly across those coals.
And then, once we're
out on this frontier,
there's not really
an option to go back.
Meaning, we're either
so far out there,
everyone knows we're doing it,
we've got to figure this out,
or they've just
back-filled your job
and you don't really have
a place to retreat to.
We go into pioneer mode--
improvising, hungry, scrappy--
where we work in simple
ways, focusing on the basics.
Doing what we need
to to survive.
And then in comes the
contribution phase.
And what we found is,
when we're inexperienced,
when we contribute we
often contribute big.
When we looked at how
experienced versus
inexperienced people
operate, we found
that, in broad industries,
people with experience
outperform people without
experience by a small margin.
That's no surprise.
But when we cut that data
by the knowledge industries,
we find that people
without experience
tend to outperform
people with experience,
particularly when the work
is innovative in nature
and in speed.
They're faster.
But then, here's
the unexplored part
of the S curve, the part that
we often don't talk about.
We've been on this rapid ascent.
Learning fast, contributing big.
And we think it's
going to continue.
Often, we find ourselves
getting comfortable.
Comfortable in
our own knowledge.
We end up sort of
protecting the status quo.
Protecting, perhaps,
the resources,
the teams that we've built.
Often we end up guiding,
advising, mentoring
other people.
We tend to pace ourselves.
Rather than moving
fast, we're consistent
and we pace ourselves
where sometimes people
are sprinting around us.
And we settle in, often
reusing what's available,
rather than reinventing
and inventing new things.
As Kahlil Gibran, the
Lebanese poet, said,
comfort is a stealthy thing.
It enters as a guest,
then becomes a host,
and then eventually
becomes a master.
And this is where the
blinders can start to kick in.
I was studying these rookies.
And again, by rookies I don't
mean young, or millennials.
I mean the way we
operate when we
are new to something
important and hard.
I found this really
interesting breed of rookies
that I came to call
"perpetual rookies."
People with deep experience,
with years of mastery,
and with a lot of
success behind them
were able to retain what I
call their "rookie smarts."
And it's not that
they stay perpetually
in this state of naivete.
It's that they
know how to toggle.
They know when it's time to
draw upon their hard-won wisdom
and experience and bring
that to bear on a problem,
but they can also use their side
of their professional skills
and their mind that thinks
and acts like a rookie.
When I studied
these professionals,
I had a number of
common characteristics.
What might you expect to see?
I found it interesting, because
a number of these things
are top of the hiring
profile here at Google.
What would you expect?
These perpetual
rookies, they are?
AUDIENCE: Curious.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LIZ WISEMAN: Curious.
First and foremost,
intellectually curious.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Quirky.
LIZ WISEMAN: Quirky.
Yeah, you know what?
I'm going to call that playful.
I found them to be
extremely playful.
And it's not the kind of playful
of Foosball tables and ping
pong tables and
slides, necessarily.
It's not about bringing play
into the work environment.
It's that work is play.
That it's fun.
That it's this
process of discovery.
It's actually this joyful thing.
When you've got that
playful orientation,
how do you deal with
mistakes and failure?
We found them to be humble.
And not necessarily someone
who has a low sense of self.
Not at all.
A word that I might
use is "teachable."
We found that they
learn, maybe what
we might call "in 360
degrees," that they
can learn from anyone
in the organization.
They're being taught by everyone
around them, even the novices.
Even the amateurs.
And lastly, we found them to
be particularly deliberate.
Mindful.
Very aware of what
they were doing.
And not only aware
of how they approach
their work, but aware
of how they maintain
this youthful orientation.
I'm going to share a
couple of the rookies,
the perpetual rookies that
I came in to encounter.
The first is Bob Hurley, the
founder of Hurley Sports.
And as Bob shared
with me his story
in building this company-- the
surf, skate, action apparel
company-- he said, at every
juncture building this company
I had no clue what I was
doing, and it turned out
to be an advantage.
And he told me this story
of building this company
with a series of what I
might call rookie moves.
But the real interesting story
was, how does he maintain this?
The company's been
wildly successful.
He's now a mature professional.
The company's part of the
Nike family of companies.
And he has this wonderful
youthful, joyful way--
and hungry way-- an intolerance
of mediocrity in the company.
He said, I have my
days where I'm stuck.
Absolutely stuck in a rut.
Feeling complacent.
Not able to see
things differently.
He said, I remembered
an experience
I had many years ago
on Huntington Beach.
And he described this
encounter he had with a surfer
who went by the name Rabbit.
It was Wayne Bartholomew.
So Bob started his
career as a surfer,
and actually shaping surfboards.
And he's out surfing
one day, and Bob's
on kind of this outer edge of
this group of elite surfers.
Huntington Beach,
it sounds to me
like it's more of a
clique in a high school.
And there's the prime waves
where the elite surfers
operate, and then there's
kind of the lesser waves.
And there are sort of degrees
of surfers and degrees of waves,
and he's surfing
on the prime waves
with these elite
professional surfers.
He loses his board.
The board goes under
the pier, so he
swims under the
pier to go get it.
And over in the small waves,
in the inferior waves,
he sees Rabbit.
And he looks at him.
Rabbit was the reigning world
champion surfer at the time,
from Australia.
And he looks over he says--
I'm a native Californian,
so I probably should be
able to do this well.
I might not be.
But he says to him something
to the effect of, like, dude,
you're a legend.
What are you doing over there?
Come on, come surf
over here with us.
The waves are righteous.
And Rabbit says to him, he goes,
well, that's kind of you, mate,
but I like to surf over
here with the kids.
It's where I get my energy.
And Bob has always
remembered that,
and he says, those days
where I'm absolutely stuck
and I can't see
things differently,
and I've lost my sense
of joy-- he said, I go
and I surf with the amateurs.
And he does it literally.
He'll grab his board.
Go down to the beach.
And not to surf with the
Hurley-sponsored professionals
that he knows.
He goes down and finds the
newcomers, the unknowns
on the beach, and
he surfs with them.
And it rebuilds his energy.
And he said, some days
the waves aren't great,
or I don't have time
to grab my board.
He said, all I do is,
I walk down the hall
and I find the rookies
in my organization.
The interns.
The new college grads.
The people who are new to
something big in the heart.
And I just spend time with
them, and they renew me.
Let me see, who else
have we got here?
We've got Francois Truffaut,
French film director who,
by age 50, had
directed 25 films.
A master.
But what was interesting,
he had this ritual.
Every time he started a
film he would walk back
to the bookstore in Paris where
he bought his very first book
when he was filming
his first film,
aspiring to be a director.
He went back to the bookstore
and he bought the book
on how to direct a
film, and he sat down
and he re-read it
so he could remember
what it was like to not
know how to produce a film,
and then he went to work.
The third is CK Prahalad.
He was a very dear
mentor to mine.
He passed about four years
ago, this phenomenal management
professor.
He was a fire hazard to
the University of Michigan,
because his lectures were
perpetually oversubscribed.
At his memorial, we're
talking to his wife, Gayatri.
And she shared with
us an experience
where, when he's a young tenured
professor-- he's now tenured
at the University of
Michigan-- and she sees
in the wastebasket
of his home office,
she sees all these
handwritten notes.
She thinks they might be these
precious research papers.
She goes to pull them
out of the trash bin
and she finds that they're
actually his teaching notes,
probably the most precious
resource a professor has.
She pulls them out
of the wastebasket.
She saves them, and she
tells CK about this.
And he thanks her, and he says,
actually I put them there.
And he said, I think my students
deserve my best thinking
and my fresh thinking
every semester.
And then lastly, this one
comes from an internet CEO.
And I asked him, how do you
keep this kind of orientation?
He said, when I am stuck
and I can't find a new idea,
and I'm struggling to
innovate, I go for a long walk.
And I walk in a
single direction and I
don't allow myself to
turn back until I've
had a legitimately new idea.
And he said, some of these walks
have been really, really long.
And then he said,
truth be told, there's
something else I do
when I'm really stuck.
And he said, you can't
use my name with this.
He said, I go into my
closet and I strip down.
I think to kind of
next to nothing.
And he said, and I just
sit and I meditate.
Now, I am not in any way
suggesting that any of you
do this, and I know
there's a meditation room
just around the corner here.
But I thought it was a
fascinating practice,
because he stripping
away more than clothes.
He stripping away
assumptions, beliefs, facts,
and trying to get down to
the very core of his thinking
so he can see things new.
Deliberate practices to renew
this youthful, fresh, hungry
way of working.
Is it possible, once
we've seen something,
to be able to see it again?
Can we see something
we've already
seen for the very first time?
Let me share an
experience where I
saw koi fish for
the very first time.
This is time I'm
working at Oracle.
I've got a really big job.
I'm running that university.
And I've also got a big family.
I have three small
children, and I'm sort of
in this really efficient,
productive mode, because I've
got a lot going on
and a lot to manage.
And my boss is starting to see
early signs of burnout in me.
And he says, Liz, I want
you to take a vacation.
In fact, I don't want to
see you for three weeks.
He kind of sentenced
me to vacation.
Now, he didn't pay for it.
He just sentenced me to it.
And so my husband and I
decided that we would serve out
our sentence in Hawaii.
That's a good place to do
this, on the island of Maui,
Kaanapali Beach, at
the Sheraton there.
And we've got three
small children.
And anyone with
three small children
knows there's
really no such thing
as a vacation with
three small children.
And we're about, maybe six
days into this vacation,
and we get up one
morning and it's time
to go down to breakfast.
My husband's sort of doing kind
of the "good husband" thing.
It's kind of one of
these husband tricks.
He says, oh here,
let me take the two.
Let me take the two
girls, our oldest,
and let me take them
down to breakfast.
He said, why don't you get
Christian and meet up with us?
Now, this is Christian.
I dug up a picture
from this trip.
This is a three-year-old,
kind of nuclear core
of creative energy.
And he is jumping on
the beds, bouncing off
the walls in his
pajamas, and I've
got to get him dressed
and sunscreened.
And I am still in my
hurry and worry mode.
Come on, come on.
Kids, sunscreen, I'm
the equipment manager
for the family.
And hurry up, come
on, quit goofing off.
Hurry up, it's time to go play.
And as I was thinking about
hurrying up my little boy,
I remembered
something my boss had
told me about a
couple months earlier.
He's a practicing
Buddhist and he
practices Buddhist meditation.
He said, I've been
trying to just
be more present, with his son,
who was a little bit older.
Letting his son kind
of set the pace,
and go where his son wanted to
go and just be with his son.
And I thought that was
an interesting challenge,
and I had tucked it away for
a time when I could do that,
and decided that day would be
the day that I would step out
of the role of leader, and
I would be the follower.
And I decided, for
that entire day,
I was going to let my son
decide where we would go
and how long we would be there.
And so, getting
him suited up, we
had to make it-- oh,
I don't know, maybe
about 100 yards from our hotel
room down to the breakfast hut
where my husband and
our two daughters
were-- and we set out, and
it was about 15 minutes
to make it the first 50 feet.
Because despite the
fact that this was just
a concrete path with
grass on both sides,
my son was seeing
everything and having
to stop to notice
every bug, every blade
of grass, every flower,
every rock, and it's
now been 15 minutes and I'm
wanting us to get to breakfast.
And I see up ahead we've got
to cross this little pond.
And the pond's got
koi fish in it.
And I am hoping, oh, I just hope
he doesn't notice the koi fish.
Well, of course he
notices the koi fish,
and of course he stops.
So following his lead, I stop.
And I say something like, oh,
look at the cool koi fish.
Those are great.
And then I point out that
breakfast is waiting for us.
Well, he's stopped.
And he's now down on his knees,
and he's playing with the fish
and he's got his
hands in the water.
And I realize I'm going
to be there for a while,
so I drop down to my knees.
And I'm squatting
down, and I can now
start to see the fish
through my son's eyes,
kind of down at his level.
And it's fun, and now
the fish are jumping up
and they're nibbling
at his fingers,
and it this kind
of koi fish frenzy.
And that's not enough for him.
He's now belly-down on this
path, playing with these fish.
And so I decide, you know what?
I might as well just
surrender to this.
And so I'm now belly-down
across the path,
having to apologize
to the people who
are climbing over us.
And there, I just
watched the koi fish,
and I watched my son play.
Now, see, I had seen
koi fish before.
I had seen koi fish in Kyoto
at the ancient temples.
I've seen koi fish at Larry
Ellison's Japanese villa.
I've seen these koi fish.
But there, I could see
that they weren't just
overgrown goldfish.
Each one was unique, with
amazing patterns and colors.
They were magnificent.
And it was there
that I truly felt
I saw koi fish for
the very first time.
And it was when I took a turn
following instead of leading
that I started to see things
that I would've missed,
and I started to
rediscover the familiar.
Can we see our work
through new eyes?
What happens when
we look at our work
through the eyes of a rookie?
And what can we do to
rekindle this rookie smarts,
despite, perhaps,
years of experience?
Let me share with you a
couple ways that we see this.
Let me offer five very,
very small experiments
that you might take
to rekindle this.
First, you might step out of
the role of leader in a meeting,
and you might step into
the role of follower.
And in that role, you might
ask the naive questions.
Not the stupid questions
that lack sort of awareness,
but the naive
questions, the diligent
questions that help
simplify and clarify.
Maybe you borrow a job.
Maybe you try on someone
else's job for a day.
Maybe you do it for a week.
Allison and I have been part of
a really interesting experiment
here at Google with the
America's marketing team.
And they were looking
at, what can they
do to bring this kind of
vibrant way of working
at its height on this team?
And they decided, we're
going to swap jobs.
And we're not going to
swap them for a day.
We're going to swap for a week.
And the team started to
pick out-- there's about,
what, 20 people on this team--
and they started to pick out,
oh I'll swap with you,
and I'll swap with you.
And they decided, you know what?
Let's go big with this.
They separated into two halves.
We were in a conference room.
One half of the group
went out the door
in the hallway this way.
The other half went out here.
And sort of reality TV-style,
I was the host in the middle,
and I would say,
OK send someone in.
It was like a game of
Red Rover, Red Rover,
send someone on over.
And they sent in
two random people,
and they walked into
the conference room
to meet the person on
their team that they
were going to swap
jobs with for a week.
And they did this over
the course of the summer,
with phenomenally interesting
experiences coming out
of doing a job you
have no idea how to do,
and building that empathy
and understanding.
So maybe you swap
jobs with someone.
Maybe you disqualify yourself.
Maybe you sign up to do a job
you have no business doing,
or lack the qualifications.
And let that drag
you into new space.
Maybe you staple
yourself to a problem.
Something that is
outside of your job,
outside of your area of
deep expertise, and you
let that problem drag
you into new space
where your current models
and templates and methods
and agendas don't
suffice, and you
build new vibrant
ways of working.
Maybe you take a
page out of CK's book
and throw away your notes--
your standard templates,
meeting agendas,
talks-- and you just
build something entirely new.
If you don't know
quite where to start,
you might take the
little rookie quiz
that will help you know where
you are in this rookie zone,
and what you might
do to rekindle that.
Let me share what I
think I fundamentally
learned in doing this research
as I studied how people operate
with experience and
how they operate
when they're brand
new to something.
Here's fundamentally
what I've learned.
I've learned that not only
is this rookie zone where
we do our very best work-- that
it provokes our best thinking,
it puts us into
learning mode-- I've
found that it's actually
our happy place.
It's the place where we find
our greatest satisfaction.
It's actually where we
find our greatest joy.
As I've asked people to think
about their own experience
as a rookie, I've heard
people say over and over,
I want to be a rookie again.
It's where I felt
the most alive.
We asked about 1,000
people to tell us
how challenged they
felt in their role
and how satisfied they
were with their job,
and what we found was a
near-perfect linear correlation
between satisfaction
and challenge,
meaning as the challenge
level of a job goes up,
so does satisfaction.
And, of course, vice versa.
As our challenge
goes down, as we
begin to know what
we're doing, we actually
become less satisfied.
Let me share this video, and
then a couple final words.
This is Zia.
She is a fourth-grade girl.
She is at the top
of the 40-meter ski
jump at Park City, Utah,
and this is her wrestle
to do this for the
very first time.
That is Zia.
And I think we all have a
little bit of Zia in us.
Again, what I have learned
from doing this research
is that it's not too
late to be a rookie.
And I think in the current work
environment, our most valuable
professionals will be those
who use all of their experience
and can maintain
their rookie smarts,
both thinking and
operating like a rookie.
I think the most valuable
leaders will be those
that help people find
the zone of discomfort.
The leaders who not only give
people a pat on the back,
but they give them a gentle
or not-so-gentle push
out into this discomfort zone.
And I think we're going
to see that the most
valuable companies are
those that, as they grow,
retain a culture of innovation,
a culture where they can think
and operate with rookie
smarts across the company.
Where they can
work with the drive
and the hunger of a newcomer.
Now, I would love to
hear what's on your mind.
An observation, a
question, anything.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any examples
of companies that have
this type of culture
that you've just described?
Not necessarily the
innovation part,
but the part about
a culture where
people feel like they can put
themselves into places where
they would fail, or sort
of at their learning
edge where they'll be able
to grow and continuously
be a rookie.
Because it strikes me that,
as companies get bigger
and there's more competition,
there's also increased risk,
and so people want to
put experts in positions.
LIZ WISEMAN: Absolutely.
And I think this
question of, are there
companies that
operate this way, it
was actually one
of the things that
drove me to do this research.
Born and raised in this area.
I've spent my whole
career in Silicon Valley,
and everyone wants to work
for the hottest company.
And there's cafe
talk about who's hot.
And it's almost like you
can set your watch ahead,
I don't know, maybe 18 months.
Put a note in your calendar to
say, is that company still hot?
And more often than
not the answer is no.
And are there companies
that can continue
to maintain this culture?
One that I have been
watching for years is Google.
I'd love to hear your
perspective on this,
but I think it's an
example of a company that
continues to hire for it,
and continues to nurture it.
I know when we started
having this conversation
with the America's marketing
team, they're like,
well this is how we operate.
We never feel like we have a
job that we're comfortable in.
We're constantly being
pushed and moved.
Vanguard is a really interesting
one, the financial services
firm.
They have this extreme
rotation culture.
There's an IT manager,
and he was suddenly
put in charge of
vendor management.
Had no clue how to do this.
He said in his first
two weeks he reached out
to 25 people trying to figure
out, what is vendor management?
What are the questions I ask?
They will move someone from
heading up a financial services
business, and then
they'll ask them
to service the CIO
for the company.
And vice versa.
Nike has a very similar kind
of culture, constantly pushing
and looking for, how do
we find the voice, often
at the bottom of
the organization?
They have something they
call the New Crew, where
they get newcomers
to the organization
that they kind of elevate up.
And they serve for a year
kind of saying the things that
need to be said
across the company.
BTS, a global consulting firm,
is another really interesting
example, hiring people with
very little experience doing
what they do-- business
simulations-- putting them
in on these projects.
Not sort of in the
typical consulting model
where they're on the
back-end of the project,
sort of grinding
out spreadsheets
but not seen by the client.
They actually push
their new talent out
in front of the
C-level officers.
But they support them
with the senior partners
who back them up.
And their orientation is, we're
going to put these newcomers up
on a tight rope, and we're
going to provide the safety
net underneath them.
But I think Google's
hiring criteria
is a very interesting one,
hiring for many of these things
that I would kind of
call rookie smarts.
Any thoughts that you see
companies that you think
do this well?
AUDIENCE: For me, I just filled
this [? 10-person ?] project
at Google.
Actually serve a certain role
of what you talk about here.
And now, for instance,
there are some [INAUDIBLE]
analysts from other
orgs just really
want to work with us
to [INAUDIBLE] project.
[INAUDIBLE] different problem
is not in her comfort room.
But I notice, even over
just several weeks,
[INAUDIBLE] already
learn a lot and then
actually it's a very
good experience for her
to learn and grow herself.
That's just an example.
Also, for me personally,
even just a [? low-key ?]
[INAUDIBLE] example.
I also think, maybe for me,
a little bit senior analyst.
And also maybe try to
find those new challenge.
That's a way I feel I can learn
more, instead of you lead,
always lead.
LIZ WISEMAN: Yeah.
And I think you do see,
from what I can see,
seeds of this in the culture.
And I think this is,
from my perspective, one
of the interesting
challenges, because I believe
that the path of
least resistance
for hot young fast-growing
technology companies
is for them to get very
comfortable and complacent.
And particularly those
who have established
a lead, the easy thing to
do is to defend that lead
and to protect that lead.
Mark Parker, the CEO of Nike,
he said something I thought
was interesting.
He said, the most
dangerous position
is to be playing it safe.
And I think one of the
applications of these ideas
is, how do companies
like Google,
who are really successful
and have gotten really
large, really smart
talented people, how
do you maintain this way
of thinking and working
despite success, and despite
that pull to keep people
where they're most valuable?
I really believe that people
are at their best and their most
valuable when they are
adjacent to what they know.
And I'm not in
any way suggesting
that people should be
taken out of one job
and moved to something
absolutely foreign.
And certainly,
certain kinds of work
that are high stakes--
like, none of us
wants a rookie heart surgeon.
You don't want a rookie dentist.
You don't want a rookie
tandem sky dive instructor.
But where we can pivot
from our place of strength
and be pointed to a foreign
problem, a new challenge,
we're at our most valuable.
One of the pieces of data
that we got in the research,
we asked people, how long after
you've been given a challenge,
how does it take
to figure it out?
Kind of stop
tumbling in the ocean
and get your head up and
figure out what you're doing.
How long does it take to be
ready for the next challenge?
When are you ready
for the next job?
And then, how quickly do
you begin to feel stale?
Now, I wasn't surprised that
people feel that it takes them
about three months to
figure out the challenge.
I wasn't surprised
that people are
ready for a new role
in about a year,
not that companies can be
doling out new opportunities
that fast.
I wasn't surprised
that people start
to feel stale after
about 24 months.
But what I was surprised
is that people say,
I'm ready for the next
challenge at three months, which
is to-the-day the amount of
time it takes to figure it out.
And most managers
can't, like I said,
dole out new jobs
and promotions.
But virtually every manager
can offer up a new challenge.
And if you're in a management
role, you might be thinking,
is this person ready
for the next hard thing?
Even within their role.
That is what I think retains
a culture of rookie smarts,
feeding your team a
steady diet of challenge.
Other questions or observations?
Or complete disagreements?
AUDIENCE: I'll give
you an agreement.
LIZ WISEMAN: I was so hoping
for disagreement, but--
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
Before I came to
Google I was probably
on the top of your S curve.
Had been there for awhile.
And then when I came
to Google, discovered
myself very much at the bottom.
But not in a good way, because I
was out of practice at learning
and I had been kind of writing
on my laurels for awhile,
I realized.
I was kind of unconscious
of it for quite awhile.
And really, I think
it wasn't until I
did a job change, changed
teams, that I was able to really
just take on something
smaller and more concentrated
that was more challenging,
to make myself come up
in other ways that I
just wasn't initially.
LIZ WISEMAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And I think maybe
a misinterpretation
of some of this
research in the book
might be, our most valuable
staff are young people
or millennials.
And I don't think that's true.
I think when people
are in a rookie zone,
they are tremendously valuable.
And when we're young, we
just have a lot more things
to be rookies about.
But I actually think our
most valuable professionals
are people with experience who
have been given an opportunity
to move outside of
their experience.
Where that experience is
valued, it's like, OK,
now I've got a new hard
thing for you to do.
It really brings out that
veteran savvy and rookie
smarts, and I think it's the
cheapest, most powerful way
to increase satisfaction
inside a company.
ALLISON: Thank you so much for
the time that you've spent.
[APPLAUSE]